a little reunion here over the zoom how
does it feel to be virtually reunited
kate oh i miss both of you so much
josiah i really wish i could
go visit you or you could visit me i
know we're hoping to go to america but
obviously
because we've got
i know well and america gets to spend a
little bit of time with you guys each
friday night now
with galley talk
[Music]
they're making you film like seven shows
out of your house
telling you thank you for noticing bryce
i'm a perfect
i have a production studio in the works
i like to call it remotely possible
productions
so i mean it's remotely possible like
we're gonna do it good enough
i was actually a little bit hesitant to
do it at first i was like
listen i've done below deck for six
years and then i watched it i lived it
i'm kind of like i'm not sure i have
anything else to say at this point
about drunk charter guests like i got no
more jokes about it
but actually i think this was
such a good idea because it is
it made me so nostalgic for working with
josiah or the johnson siblings
or i mean just seeing everybody really
even if i didn't work with them i was
like oh i miss i miss colin
i because obviously i was watching julia
who i've not
worked with or anything but i'm normally
watching it with my partner michael and
he's normally saying
is it really this stressful i mean
you're working on a yacht in the
caribbean
isn't it not just really nice so now i
can finally watch it with someone that's
done it
as well so they can get the stress that
we actually go through
except it's not us so we get to just
laugh
yeah exactly we're not actually involved
we just get to drink
and laugh at the people that are
involved it's amazing
i was gonna say is that the best part of
this thing that you just get to
you get the kind of the fun part the
interview part the commentary part
without
having to live through all the bs and
then you can turn your tv off and go to
your own bed and sleep
i'm really enjoying it
it doesn't give you any fomo from making
the show
or being on a yacht i will say there was
one scene where it's like oh gosh maybe
i do miss it
and that was seeing the beautiful
caribbean backdrop
but that might just be because i'm so
starved for vacations nobody traveling
you know like i miss vacations i think i
need to remind myself i miss vacations
watching you guys watch the show
obviously it makes the fans
miss seeing you as team members or on
the show what would it take
to get you to sign up for just one more
charter on below deck i have an idea of
how this could work
josiah i think you should be the chief
stu next season
and i i would come back to be the third
stew thirsty gets the worst jobs you
have to be saying oh you're down in the
laundry room hiding i just be down there
with my music and be like hey guys
like you know i get to be part of it
with zero responsibility like
when you're the third student you don't
realize how wonderful
you are you don't realize how lucky you
are until you become
second and chieftain you think ah i wish
i was third
third too you don't have to even look or
talk to the guests the whole time if you
don't want to know how to open a bottle
of wine
you just stay down there privacy you
don't have to like
you can wear your pajamas who cares
nobody's looking at you
josiah i always wondered why you never
came back for another season
did you give up yachting after that
season um no i didn't necessarily give
up yachting i
um i took a bit of a break from it and
um i've done a few kind of freelance
things i'm not
i don't see myself going back full time
you know traveling all the time because
you kind of can't necessarily have a
relationship you can't
you know it's quite hard to have a
normal itch life but i'll go back and do
um a season here or a season there for
sure so maybe kate's dream of you being
a chief stew might happen
i'll be the best search too ever
after i'm done with the idea i won't
even make mustard gas
because honestly i i didn't think that
was a thing
one of your staff was using bleach mixed
with soap
which causes a gas uh-huh they actually
used to
work too as mustard gas i immediately
called captain like is this true
you know miracle we survived because i
got my laptop i was like
can you make i mean i definitely did i
was soaking things like
because inevitably launching mistakes
happen so i'm like just throw in a
bucket of bleach and cross your fingers
we'll come back to it later
like too much detergent and it foams up
i think
that's a bit extreme with elizabeth did
well yeah she
started chemical warfare on board um
kate i talked to captain lee at the
beginning of the season and he says his
dream is for you to come back and be a
charter guest oh well yeah obviously um
as soon as we're allowed to travel i
would like that to happen
i would simultaneously be the best and
the worst charter guesses kind of like
when you go out to
eat at a restaurant but you've worked at
restaurants before i'm so kind and
pleasant but the minute they walk away
from the table
i feel bad for the person dining with me
i'm like you know i did say no tomato
and they put extra it's fine
it's fine it's fine it's fine i said
medium rare it's actually uh well done
it's fine i'm not gonna say anything but
i'm just saying you know
like i would like know when they were
like cutting corners or something
and then they come back everything okay
and you go oh yeah that was fine
oh yeah thank you oh my gosh it was what
would be so hard i mean i shouldn't even
refill my water
but also like um i know that
just muscle memory anytime i step foot
on a boat like
big small whatever what size boat i just
like
almost like go into i'm like okay so we
need to drink how much ice do we have do
we have ice okay let me i'll make you
drink
your coke's looking low okay i'll give
you a refill i would probably end up
helping out
automatically go into yes hosting mode
yes it would be hard to disconnect the
two
mm-hmm kate you recently shared a video
of how you used to have to get the
lights turned off
while aboard the ship you had to wave
the cameras so that whoever was in
master control watching knew you
needed darkness what else would surprise
fans about how this show is put together
because it's a lot of moving parts on a
small it's a yacht but small quarters
when you
it's it's a yacht but the yacht gets
smaller
and smaller the more people are on it my
first thing
like i did freelance routing for a long
time um before i joined below deck and
whenever i joined a new boat i would be
like
oh hi and i brought you this box of
chocolates from my hometown oh
you know because you know like you're
about to live and work with people on a
boat like
start joining the boat kissing some ass
you know like here you go here's a
present so i
brought one box of chocolates for the
yacht crew of below deck
and i brought one box of chocolates for
the production crew
so i was like here there are
75 people a production crew like i
thought
i thought it's gonna be like six like a
guy with a camera
and like maybe a director i didn't know
what
entertainment world even really was so
they're like
four pa they took it was like thanks
jose do you have any memories from
making the show that surprised you about
how the whole thing was put together
yeah well very similar i kind of thought
oh i'll just go on the boat it'll be
like
normally there may be like one or two
camera people following us around and i
got on and it's like
it's it's almost like you know how they
say that workplaces are like a swan
and they were like gliding along that's
basically us working and then
the crew like are paddling their feet
below and you don't really know what's
going on until it's behind the camera
you know what i mean i love you so much
i believe this thing
people are used to it's like a duck a
duck sliding across the water with your
feet
but for josiah he's like you know this
is like a swan
we have to elevate it we have to make it
a little more british
no josiah's swan everybody else says
duck
do you have your number one below deck
regret whether something it was
something you
did or something you didn't get to do
that you would like to go back and do
i have never gone down the slide that's
what i was gonna say
i've never done it i have never been
down a slide and i've never jumped off a
boat
like i've done swim platform but i've
never jumped off like
the top deck of the boat and i've always
wanted to do that
yeah that's fun i don't know i hear the
slides flood it's just cause like
usually there was only when the guests
were at the beach party so i was using
that time to like
do stuff on the boat and like maybe i
had time but also like
it would take so long they came back my
hair is like soaking wet
yeah and like do you want to go down the
slide and then have to shower and get
changed all
right i'm gonna lay down 15 minutes when
there are guests on board and that's the
only time the slide comes out
is when our guests on board i've got
other stuff to do
so we got to get you back on boat you
can be third stew you can go down the
slide and josiah can be chiefs too and
jump off the top of the boat
season nine or a charter guest third
stuart charter guest
come back as the third stu quit after
one charter then
come back at the end of the season as
the final charter guest
i love this i love this for me it's so
exciting